وجه هاني متناقضان للحياه الفارسيه صفوف
طويله لمن ان ينتظرون الدخول الى سيرك
الشتاء التاريخي لمشاهده عروض متنوعه وعلى
بعد امطار سمح هدوء ما بعد العاصفه لسكان
الحيه والعابرين فيه بمعاينه الاضرار
سيارات قلبت او احرقت وواجهات زجاجيه
تحطمت جزئيا وغضب كردي تفجر بعد ان اقدم
يمني متطرف اقر بعنصريته على قتل ثلاثه
افراد وجرح ثلاثه اخرين صباح الجمعه اقر
المعتدي ايضا انه توجه صباح الجمعه الى
ضحيه سند قتلى اكبر عدد من المهاجرين لكن
قله عدد الناس في الشارع دفعته للعوده الى
باريس حيث اقدم على جريرته الثلاثيه حصيله
المواجهات واحد وثلاثون شرطيا جرحوا وجرح
متظاهر ودعى المسؤولون الاكراد الغاضبين
الى الهدوء في مقاله وزير العدل الفرنسي
مطمئنا الاكراد ان فرنسا كلها في عزاء وان
دعمنا لكم ثابت لا يتزعزع